the US Military Academy at West Point is
investigating a deadly crash during a
training exercise the rollover yesterday
killed one cadet and left 21 others
injured Don Dahler is in Highland Falls
New York near the Academy so Don what do
we know about this accident good morning
to you good morning well the cadets were
here on a summer training program the
accident unfolded on the very same day
that the country pause to commemorate
the d-day celebrations or our
honorariums I should say the 75th
anniversary thereof and the
superintendent here at West Point
described this as a tragic day for the
community we don't know the details of
how the accident actually investigators
want to know exactly how a tactical
vehicle packed with cadets overturned in
the woods near the Academy early
Thursday morning they were headed to
land navigation training when they were
in the back of the the truck the light
medium tactical vehicle like the one
seen here had a soft canvas top and
weighed more than 11,000 pounds 20
cadets all rising seniors in the class
of 2020 were seated in the cargo bed of
the truck driven by two soldiers they
were said to be driving in rough terrain
you can see by looking around very hilly
we want to make sure that our soldiers
and our cadets train in realistic
training environment so this is a part
of our realistic training one cadet was
killed the 19 other cadets as well as
the two soldiers suffered
non-life-threatening injuries the West
Point superintendent said accidents like
these are rare but is not common for
these vehicles to turn over but it has
happened before
back in June 2016 at Fort Hood nine
soldiers died after their vehicle
flipped in a flood stream in 2009 13
were injured after their truck
overturned at Fort Bragg the
superintendent said the West Point
community is mourning but would respond
with strength I mean this is the United
States Army were strong we're strong
here at West Point president Trump
expressed his condolences via Twitter
calling this a terrible accident West
Point is expected to release the name of
the cadet later today gale Don thank you
very much